Caron Butler you can see Quran during
the special playoff editions of NBA
gametime live Saturday and Sunday on NBA
TV
TNT continues to have the expansive NBA
playoff coverage Sunday at 6:30 Eastern
with the Nuggets Blazers game for Ron
Butler joining us on the program
Quran good morning how are you you're a
juco transfer to uconn right prep smooth
I would say Maine Central Institute okay
now when you're coming out of that what
what is recruiting like back then how
crazy was recruiting for you oh man it
was amazing because you know I was the
number one prep player in the country
and I had pretty much every team coming
to watch me at Maine Central Institute
head coach max good at the time at the
New England prep school and it was just
an amazing experience you know and I was
trying to go to the the best situation
for me where I can excel the most and at
the time you know social media wasn't
available so the trending thing was to
get as close to ESPN as possible and I
went to the University of Connecticut
for right by the University University
of ESPN we called it would you tell me
if you got illegal offers oh yeah of
course did you yes you know what to tell
me to school but tell me the offer what
was Caron Butler worth on the open
market back then hey listen I think you
know a lot of people came in with you
know extremely high bids you know
anything from 80,000 to 100,000 dollars
and what I was saying is you know if you
can be bought you can be sold and you
know I wasn't for sale on the market you
know I wanted the college experience and
because I went through adversity as a
kid as a young age I felt insult you
know when people came to me you know
trying to buy me for my talent but what
I can bring to a team and I felt like
the biggest asset was me just you know
coming with my talent and you know they
closure of the same things that I've
never been exposed to and not going to
be asset to any organization but also
you're getting money but then they also
there's people family jobs you know they
they they're setting people up here yeah
and I don't know if you experienced that
as well I didn't experience that part of
this of the games because you know I
never took no bribe or any offer like
that you know coach Coach Calhoun with
the straight as possible he said you
come here you're gonna be family for
life and he never lied about that and
what he did tell me is that you know
conductive criticism is gonna make you
break you and if you come to the
University of Connecticut you'll be the
best possible version of yourself
leaving here and he didn't lie about
that either one of the best decisions
that I ever made he came to me looking
in my eyes as a man and I think my
upbringing was a little different
because I've been through a lot of
adversity early and I was just certain I
was just in search for somebody to treat
me as an equal not to try to come to me
with any type of bribery and that's
exactly how you came to do you think if
we allow these these students these kids
to come out of high school and go right
to the pros or are we gonna be done with
paying these players or with that or
will that continue I think it will
continue a that's it but also I think
that you know it has to be visited where
you know when when kids are young enough
and talented enough you can't have a
roadblock in that situation effect if
they're capable their skillset and their
if their talent is able to put them on a
platform where they can excel in the NBA
space immediately why not
you know that should be opportunity for
them you know that's a god-given talent
that you know they was touched with and
they should be able to explore that as
early as possible but I don't think it's
gonna change much because that's just a
game unfortunately and it's a damaging a
lot of you know careers and also you
know it's costly to a lot of families
because you know once you exposed to
that type of environment you know it
hinders them and they're great
he's Caron Butler the Turner Sports NBA
TV analyst Joan
dan Patrick show I brought this up about
15 minutes ago that there are certain
players you game for game plan for and
that's the entire defense I think that
that's what happens with James Harden
it happens with Steph Curry and it
happens with the Greek freak I don't
know if any other player has another
team that is geared towards stopping you
in these playoffs and I know Kevin
Durant's wonderful but I think that the
Rockets are more concerned with Steph
Curry's three than Katie's mid-range
jumper and therefore he might get single
coverage where you're always going to
have a shadow on Steph Curry because if
Steph gets going from three-point range
that's when you die same with James
Harden I think the Celtics have done
that the same thing with the Greek freak
your thoughts on that assessment well I
think you right to a certain offense but
you know coming to rest his nickname is
easy money sniper
meaning that he's a walking bucket
anything like that with a seven footer
that can be able to you know put the
ball on the floor introduce you to
hip-hop from any facet of the game if he
did any type of airspace if he's walking
into the gym with the airspace because
you cannot get to a shot can't get to
the shooters pocket so the game plan is
to stop him but he makes the game look
effortless he's always catching the ball
of his sweet spot anywhere from 17 on
end he's getting to the logo his
isolation position every time you turn
around the face you which I touched on
is you just can't get to it this pocket
and even when you take away a guy like
Steph Curry he's still gonna average
somewhere between 17 to 21 points per
game and then you have the illusion of
conclusion you have there Hampton five
which enable capela to even get out
there not because he's not a heck of a
player but he can't keep up with the
pace Andre Iguodala
draymond Green playing the five and
numerous times
you got five guys on the floor that's
just multi-talented very versatile they
could facilitate they can stretch you
out on the perimeter if you put the ball
on the floor so they stretch you out and
they be okay do the necessary real
estate just to isolate and that's the
reason why it's been so crazy ever since
came on and asserted herself with the
Golden State Warriors because there was
a they were they were there hardcover
before that but now you put one of the
best isolation players ever to play the
game a bad for not just this error but
ever to play the game of basketball how
do you stop that why would he leave this
environment though Quran why would he
leave Golden State look you know I think
that you know so many times in life we
we don't know what fulfills other
people's destiny right because some
people chase goes for some people chase
missions and I think Kevin Durant has
you know changed some goals which was
his check points in his life and in his
career on his broader goal is his
mission and you know if you're going to
go somewhere else in Excel that's his
right to do so but let's not forget that
every year they've been in the finals
every year to fit so far they won the
NBA championship and he's been the
Finals MVP so if he's three for three
and it's time with the Golden State
Warriors and he elects to go somewhere
else
fairs changed not a robbery and that's
his independent right to do so and I
think that so many times we're trying to
figure out the who the what in the
holler but we can't have sports rage
when these athletes are like to do
something that's independently fulfilled
their mission it happens all the time
with you know owners and sports where
you go what the hell why did you tray
that player they like to do something
that fulfill their mission they haven't
a broader view of the games for their
self in their organization and their fan
base and you know they want to put up a
very interesting product out there so
when they do it you know close to them
they're brilliant they're the best
owners and they say and they've lifting
its face for the next 30 to 40 years but
when players do it their legacies are
you know painted or why did he choose to
do that why do you break up that and
then we have sports rage I would not
elect to do that I'm happy for him
either way and I think that he was
making an excellent decision by staying
where he's at now but once we agency
if you go somewhere else I'm following
because I think he's one of the best
players ever to play today with
basketball
yeah he is I just it feels like Golden
State would be a place where it's just
fun you can go out there now I know the
expectation level is really high it's
like when LeBron was with the Miami Heat
and they went on that long winning
streak and they were like man we're just
that we're just tired of this you know
you got to play and you got a winning
streak got to go out there and play hard
instead of relaxing a little bit during
the regular season that's why I'm
curious and and I know that Katie is
wired differently and I appreciate that
I just and I do think he's leaving
Golden State and I do think he wants to
not be the villain he's the guy who
ruined basketball according to people
like you went to Golden State how could
you do that if he goes to the Clippers
or the nets or the Knicks then it's
different then Katie's looked at
differently and I think he's as
sensitive as any athlete we have today
and I applaud him if he stays and if he
wants to leave you know it's his
prerogative and I'm sure that he'll have
reasons behind that but you know he
still got the that the problem with the
NBA Quran is we always look towards next
season it feels like we've been looking
towards next season how many seasons in
a row now where's LeBron going mine good
where he he's been the player where
LeBron was in the Eastern Conference and
he's the only player on this planet in
their associations that's a watch and
what I mean by that is if Kevin Doubront
James goes out to score if he has some
of the most reward Finals appearances
and performances ever so reward that
even in even when losing he was still
considered MVP of the finest 3579
four blocks in the basketball game but
equally matched from the other side with
Kevin Durant do you think current do you
think Quran do you think Kevin Durant
will ever be recognized as better than
LeBron James when their careers are over
it's you know what it's so much
basketball left that you can't say that
but I will tell you this when you tell
the story of basketball you can't tell
the story of basketball without
mentioning both of them one and then
when you talk about who had to go
through whom right because we're always
talking about the go comparison yeah
he's like well nobody can get past
Jordan you know Jordan was the world
blocks of Patrick Ewing and Karl Malone
Charles Barkley so many of those guys
and then all of a sudden we say well who
was the road block for LeBron James on
the back end his career or even in the
prime of his career when Kevin Durant
elected to go to the Golden State
Warriors Kevin Durant was the roadblock
capping the rent was the road block the
Warriors encountered the rent feature
and Kevin Durant was the road block yeah
man they won before he got there that's
true they did win before he get there
but he's the the piece that now can't
nobody deal and that's why we're but
have this conversation where we could
say we can look forward to next season
because we pretty much know us they're
probably going to happen this season
again because of Kevin Durant's on the
worst how's the hair looking back a
little bad I got I got my waves noise
[Laughter]
what did your kid say to the studio
surprised y'all tonight in my yard you
remember the kid in play flat top that's
such what you need to bring out great
stuff great to have you on we appreciate
your time and good luck with this career
Thank You Quran
that's a Quran Butler Turner Sports NBA
analyst if you missed any of the
interviews on this program from the
mercedes-amg man cave go to the Dan
Patrick show app where you can watch and
listen from inside the mercedes-amg man
cave Mercedes AMG driving performs for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel two three
9:00 on Direct TV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app